y'all just won season 31 of Dancing With
the Stars how about that
the winners and new champions of Dancing
With the Stars Are
Charlie and Mom
oh my gosh you're a shell shocked you
looked shocked I didn't know what to
think it was it happened so fast did it
yeah yeah I gotta tell you after that
freestyle there was not a dry eye in the
house you guys really tugged out some
heartstrings I mean your mom your sister
your fellow teammates and Pros what did
you guys feel in that moment because I
know when the dance ended you were
fighting back tears
I mean I think we were just I mean I was
just happy and proud to have told both
of our stories and close it out with the
bang and I was just so happy that we got
to do that for the both of us it felt
really good I mean Mark what are you
going to take away from this partnership
in this season of Dancing
it's just like a lifetime of memories
that will last forever you know the work
lives forever you know the the quality
time you spend the friendships you make
the relationships you make that's what
lasts forever you know so I had to I had
a I had a fantastic time and that last
dance too like the pack I'm not much of
a like well I am I am a crier I guess
but that package like
and then doing that dance like all of it
together just
because it was almost felt it just felt
good you know I can't explain what it
felt like well because it was so much
more than a routine it's your guys's
lives and uh what will you take away
from this experience you know now that
you found this love of dance again I
think I've just learned so much that I
don't even know and this is
I don't think that this is hit yet yeah
I'm just this I don't even know what to
think I'm just very excited you should
be it gave you some life right it gave
you some life again mark it was so
amazing to see you back can we expect
you back next season it's a little early
for all that right now you know
[Music]